you
well I said I never really got into
Shrek and I always sort of thought it
was an overrated comedy Shrek 2 I think
is one of the greatest comedies ever
made its attention to detail its speed
its jokes its puns its visuals its
characters its pacing its timing this is
a comedic marvel I could watch this
movie a million times and never get
tired of it when I saw the first Shrek
film this is the movie I thought I was
gonna get it turns out I just had the
way to flick later but you know what
it's still worth it the story Shrek and
Fiona are now both ogres yeah kind of
spoiler from the last film who are now
off to visit her parents in order to get
their blessing the parents are of course
shocked that Fiona is now and
permanently an ogre and then on top of
that she married an ogre the king
especially is not pleased with this
Sookie hires a hit man to go after him
for a hit cat by the name of Puss in
Boots voice man Tonio Bender's this
character is so popular and so funny he
would eventually get his own movie
spin-off we also find out there's a
subplot going on with an evil fairy
godmother and a prince named Prince
Charming
who want to seize control by having
Fiona marry him instead of Shrek
but Shrek just wants to make his bride
happy and decides to take a potion to
turn him human thinking it will not only
get the blessing of her parents but also
her love in return
okay here's a perfect example of why I
love this movie when at their house
Shrek looks outside and sees a bunch of
guards waiting all they have to do is
play these royal horns and the guy has
to read his message but instead they do
this
enough regi just that one little tidbit
this movie is full of great moments like
that tons of little touches here and
there every second is trying to throw a
joke at you and the majority of them hit
bull's eyes these are well thought out
and well put together but to make it
even better the characters are really
likable I actually think the romance
between Shrek and Fiona is very
legitimate I like the resolution they
have at the end I like how far he's
willing to go I like the fact that
through half of the movie he doesn't
look like his normal self that's kind of
a risky move donkey is funny yeah I
actually found Eddie Murphy hilarious in
this cuz I don't know they gave him
funny things to say they also continued
those great ideas with the fairytale
world like they go too far far away
which looks like Beverly Hills there's a
low down bar where all the fairytale
villains hang out called the poison
apple isn't that a great name the
villain is a great villain and her plan
is really pretty diabolical the climax
is one of my favorites with a little bit
of a wink to ghostbusters and one hell
of a great song number this is one of
those scenes where I was invested
excited and laughing the whole time I've
talked about before in the past I don't
even know what else to say about it's
just so good if you really get angry at
me for not thinking Shrek is one of the
best comedies of all time take some
comfort in that I think the sequel is it
had great heart it had great comedy it
had a great story it had great
characters and had great animation it's
just great
you